wohnen mieten kaufen fuß themen unserer
zeit menschen können sich die mieten
nicht mehr leisten ein eigenheim für
unsere generation oft undenkbar ich
finde es einfach ungerecht dass wir uns
hier in dem stadtteil einfach keine
andere wohnung leisten kann habt ihr
schon mal darüber nachgedacht ein haus
zu bauen wenn ja glückwunsch aber er
gehört zu einer bedrohten art für unsere
eltern war das irgendwie normal war
familie und dann haust aber ehrlich
gesagt das hat sich geändert vielleicht
kommt er aber auch zur miete und dann
habt ihr sicher gemerkt die preise die
explodieren immer mehr von unserem
einkommen geht fürs wohnen drauf
besonders heftig ist dass in den
großstädten in berlin zum beispiel ist
in den letzten fünf jahren der
durchschnittliche quadratmeterpreis mehr
als 40 prozent gestiegen warum wohnen
immer teurer wird und andere damit ihr
geld verdienen wie im mittelalter und
unsere generation sich kein eigenheim
mehr leisten kann erfahrt ihr in diesem
video
sie erklären was boden und mieten
miteinander zu tun haben müssen erst mal
klären was wir meinen wenn wir boden
sagen wir meinen damit nicht
landwirtschaftlich genutzte flächen auch
ein spannendes thema aber hier nicht so
wichtig wir meinen wohnflächen also
flächen auf dem gebäude stehen oder mal
stehen werden das ding ist die
bodenpreise sind explodiert wir haben
euch mal diese karte erstellt anhand
dieser karte lässt sich ziemlich gut
ablesen wo die bodenpreise in den
letzten 25 jahren am stärksten gestiegen
sind das sieht man vor allen dingen den
größeren städten sehr gut in münchen
hamburg stuttgart berlin oder düsseldorf
aber auch in eher ländlichen regionen zb
in rheinland-pfalz oder in sachsen
lassen sich preissteigerungen
feststellen
aber was hat jetzt eure miete mit dem
wohnung zu tun der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler professor
löhr versteht langen zu geschätzten mit
dem boden und der erklärt das so der
bogen markt ist der vorgelagerte mark
auf dem wohnungsmarkt ergeben sich dann
nachher die symptome phänomene also das
was wir da zum beispiel sehen diese
mieterhöhung in den großen städten wie
münchen und den bayerischen wald in
münchen die zahlen sie mehr als 20 euro
pro quadratmeter miete im bayerischen
wald vielleicht fünf oder sechs euro pro
quadratmeter bietet ja wofür zahlt man
das denn ganz einfach man bezahlt für
den boden sehr gut ist eine riesige
umverteilungsmaschine das ist die eine
geschichte also kein boden eigentümer
setzt den bogen selber in der das was
eigentlich ziemlich bitter denn der
boden ist kein gut wie jedes andere und
es sollte auch nicht so behandelt werden
das hat sogar das
bundesverfassungsgericht vor über 50
jahren festgestellt
der grund und boden ist weder
volkswirtschaftlich noch in seiner
sozialen bedeutung mit anderen
vermögenswerten gleichzustellen
es gibt leute die können sich in den
akten legen schlafengehen am nächsten
tag erreicht haben nichts beweist die
leistung standen von
unternehmen die leistung statt vom
lohnsteuer zahlen die leistungen standen
von verbrauchern die ihre verbrauch
steuern gezahlt haben und dieses geld
hat dann standorten in wert gesetzt und
diese in wertschätzung für den privat
einkassiert das ist meines erachtens
haben wir auch nicht so eine
marktwirtschaft zu suchen oder das ist
schlicht und ergreifend
etwas was man eigentlich im mittelalter
angenommen hätte mit feudale
gesellschaften aber nicht nur bei uns
aber trotzdem wir haben ist immer noch
riesig so gewähren sind wir also was im
wohn betrifft noch im mittelalter
verhaftet die realität sieht leider oft
so aus unternehmen verdienen viel geld
mit dem grund und boden aber wieso wird
überhaupt so viel im boden investiert
also warum ist das so lukrativ zum einen
der niedrige leitzins weil der momentan
gleich null ist stürzen sich alle auf
sichere anlagen und das ist zum beispiel
der boden zum anderen sind viele
menschen den letzten jahren in große
städte gezogen und das hat die nachfrage
nach wohnraum erhöht wir leben also eine
echt problematische entwicklung auf dem
bodenmarkt von der wir eigentlich nur
die spitze des eisbergs mitbekommen
steigende mieten und steigende
baulandpreise und die treffen unsere
generation besonders die lbs studie
zeigt heute können sich nur noch halb so
viele mieter zwischen 30 und 44 ein
eigenheim leisten wie noch vor zehn
jahren ihr anteil ist von 8,7 auf nur
noch 4,8 prozent geschrumpft als folge
der steigenden bodenpreise passieren
dann dinge wie auf einem ehemaligen
güterbahnhof in leipzig mitten in
leipzig liegt dieses diesem gelände seit
jahren brach
eigentlich soll hier ein neues
stadtviertel entstehen mit platz für
über 3000 menschen früher waren hier
betriebe nachts konnte man tanzen gehen
also hier war eine komplette gebäude
reihe wo der club oft bin war eigentlich
ein solostück versteckt auch abzutragen
aber ich meine das ist noch kein
einziges haus entstanden
die deutsche bahn hat den ehemaligen
güterbahnhof 2005 verkauft ich habe so
ein paar satelliten fotos gucken was
passiert ist hier so die letzten jahre
2006 beispielsweise liegen noch die
schienen
die bilder zeigen in den vergangenen 15
jahren wurden hier schienen abgetragen
und häuser abgerissen
viel hat sich hier nicht getan und das
ärgert auch die die hier leben
wir räumen nach wie vor nur erdreich wie
man gerade sieht wir haben auch gehört
dass die firma die das ursprünglich
entwickelt hat das wohl weiter verkauft
hat riechst du musst gebäude und schulen
den campus oktober soll das team ist
ökologisch alles gemacht werden mit
grünen dächern mit
wasserrückhaltebecken aber mit
sicherheit nicht normal das tutorial
werden das ist überhaupt
keine miete leisten kann obwohl hier
noch nicht gebaut wurde soll sich der
preis der brache verzehnfacht haben
leipzig ist nur ein beispiel von vielen
das zeigt dass sie etwas extrem schief
läuft bodenpreise steigen seit jahren in
ganz deutschland theoretisch sollten
kommunen land kaufen ganz praktisch
haben sie es aber verkauft vor allen
dingen den 90ern und in 2009 und das hat
was mit haushaltsplänen und schulden zu
tun denn viele kommunen haben ein
dauerproblem laut bertelsmann studie
werden die kommunen im jahr 2020 ohne
die finanzhilfen von bund und ländern
handlungsunfähig gewesen und geld ist
schon lange ein problem ein blick aus
den schulden war dass die kommunen ihren
boden verkauft haben das haben sie in
den 90ern und 2000ern getan das hat zwar
viel geld in die kassen gespült aber
eben nur kurzfristig das gibt auch
helmut dedy zu geschäftsführer des
deutschen städtetags die städte haben in
teilen in den letzten 10 20 jahren auch
grundstücke verkauft und
teilweise um den haushalt zu sanieren
teilweise vielleicht auch aus purer not
rückblickend betrachtet würde ich sagen
so ganz klug war das nicht und heute die
kommunen haben ihre böden immer noch
nicht zurück geholt aber wie auch wenn
die preise davon galoppieren und die
kommunen so klamm sind deswegen haben
wir eine anfrage gestellt bei den 80
größten städten in deutschland und haben
gefragt wie viel boden gehört euch
eigentlich und wollt ihr wieder welchen
erwerben was uns besonders aufgefallen
ist viele städte können oder wollen uns
nicht sagen wie viel grund und boden
ihnen gehört 20 städte antworten gar
nicht 19 machen keine angaben oder weil
ich in der frage aus nur knapp die
hälfte konnte beziehungsweise wollte
unsere fragen komplett beantworten im
durchschnitt besitzen die städte 9,2
prozent ihrer wohnflächen aber die
verteilung ist sehr unterschiedlich
salzgitter besitzt zb nur rund 0,7
prozent duisburg hingegen 21 prozent das
sind krasse unterschiede und noch viel
schlimmer offensichtlich wissen auch
viele städte gar nicht was mit ihren
grundstücken auf ihrem brett geschieht
das ist ein ganz zentraler vermögenswert
den sie da haben und sie wissen nicht
wie viele haben wir überhaupt was ist es
wert und so weiter und so fort also
insoweit ist das schon erschreckend also
bitte verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
also fassen wir noch mal zusammen viele
sagen der boden sollte der allgemeinheit
gehören momentan verdienen aber vor
allen dingen private investoren an den
wertsteigerungen weil sie da mit einer
hohen rendite rechnen können mit schuld
daran sind die kommunen die diesen boden
an die investoren verkauft haben der
bodenmarkt ist im wohnungsmarkt
vorgelagert heißt wird der boden teuer
wird später auch die miete teurer was
uns zur frage bringt gibt es lösungen
für das problem hat die politik
irgendwelche ideen zum einen einen
mieten deckel also eine mietobergrenze
und die absenkung der mieten die darüber
liegen das hat zum beispiel das land
berlin gemacht ist aber vom
bundesverfassungsgericht kassiert worden
weil es die kompetenzen des landes
überschreitet und es löst auch nicht
unser eigentliches problem die
steigenden bodenpreisen eine weitere
idee ist die bodenwert steuer der
gedanke ist nicht neu er kommt unter
anderem von einem spd politiker hat sich
auch ein vogel und der hat ihn in den
1970 er schon geäußert der kerngedanke
ist die boden wertsteigerung kommt durch
die gemeinschaft also ist es auch nur
legitim diesen wert zu besteuern der
investor muss also ein teil seiner
gewinne abgeben die dritte idee ist dass
kommunen selbst eigentümer ihrer bösen
werden und da lohnt sich ein blick ins
ausland singapur zum beispiel besitzt 90
prozent seiner böden und verkauft sie
nicht weiter sondern verpachtet sie am
ende der pacht erb der staat diese böden
zurück und verdient währenddessen
zusätzlich ähnlich macht es übrigens
auch hongkong beide haben einen hohen
lebensstandard was man auch damit
erklären kann dass sie die gewinne aus
den böden investieren zum beispiel in
bildung oder im nahverkehr klar singapur
und hongkong kann man jetzt nicht
unbedingt mit deutschland vergleichen
beide sind viel kleiner aber die idee
findet immer mehr anhänger auch in
deutschland entdecken städte die
erbpacht wieder zum beispiel vergibt
frankfurt bauland nur noch im
erbbaurecht und auch die berliner
landesregierung hat 2016 im
koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben dass
sie erbpacht stärker nutzen will wieviel
geld investoren wirklich mit dem boden
machen und wer sich die taschen
vollstopfen findet in der mediathek
heraus dort gibt es eine ganze folge die
spur zum thema boden